you were shooting an episode of Downton
Abbey and you get a surprise guest you
find that a surprise guest is coming who
was it yes it was the Duchess of
Cambridge came to give us a lovely visit
Kate Middleton I don't know all the
titles exactly so Kate Middleton and is
just gonna pop in yep so she just popped
in and yeah we were very excited and
Michelle Dockery and I were the only
people actually filming that day
everybody else was in to meet her but
and obviously there's a lot of security
that comes with it as well you know I be
no she's she's royalty so four days
before we have you know the police
coming around sniffer dogs and it's all
like at least it feels like a huge event
that's what happens when I go anywhere
they lock down the area and there's a
lot of you know and egos the day before
and check everything out just he has a
peanut allergy so so anyway so they're
coming and it's probably that thing
where there's because I know when you
around high-powered people in America
they say oh they're coming in what yeah
yeah so Michelle Dockery and I were
filming and someone kept rushing in and
saying right she's gonna be here in 10
minutes
okay 5-10 minutes she's gonna be here 9
minutes I okay right 9 minutes and so
you're just getting more and more
nervous over eat on the Korean that's
like 30 seconds like okay right so we're
doing this scene and she's very
beautiful and lovely and she has this
amazing aura when she walks in the room
so she walked in the room and Michelle
and I had to sort of carry on the scene
so before we actually said hello we had
to act right in front of her and she was
literally stood there that's possible
that you know I got a bit jittery I know
anyway she came over to say hi
afterwards and yeah I said oh hello
lovely to meet you and she said oh it
feels strange you know been in in your
bedroom because we're doing a scene in
Lady Mary's bedroom and I said yeah not
many people get to call me Lady Mary's
bedroom and then I was like oh my god
what if I just said something that could
be taken really yeah I thought do I say
don't draw attention to it and I'm just
gonna be quiet the answer the answer
would be don't draw attention to it yeah
so I didn't and neither did she she was
very gracious yeah
see what I did there